face stephen metz for the second time
this season making his 19th start of the
season first career start here at rogers
center here's a hot hitting ahmed
rosario to wind in the pitch and he
swings and lines the single to center
so ahmed rosario with his fourth hit in
this series and that'll bring up jose
ramirez
fly bob
springer excuse me grichik is in center
as springer's the d.h and sorry hustles
back but first ramirez flies out to
center field fran mill reyes d-h batting
270 one ball two strikes
change-up swinging of this matt's off to
a good start he gets a strikeout to end
the inning j.c mejia to the mound faced
the blue jays earlier this season when
he was working out of the bullpen and he
went an ending in two-thirds of
scoreless relief george springer's the
banner leading it off george springer
jumps on the first pitch get out of here
bo he's done it again
his third leadoff home run this season
his 42nd career leadoff home run on the
first pitch
of the ball game he is on fire blue
chase as a team are hitting 400 on the
first pitch
springer loves it you hunt fastball that
first pitch of the ball game he gets it
and he is all over it and now it's first
and second so here's corey dickerson he
was over four in his blue jays debut
last night as the d8
cory dickerson drives one to the wall in
right
simeone's in this score bushets being
waved around third here comes the throw
to the plate not in time corey dickerson
will go to third on the throw and the
blue jays have scored three here in the
bottom of the first
cory dickerson's first hit as a blue jay
a two-run devil
randall grichik steps in
ground ball up the middle through for a
base hit as dickerson comes in to score
and randall grichik picks up an rbi
oscar mercado has the indian second hit
of the night both hits line drives
singles to center field here's owen
miller
now the curveball came right back with
it and gets a strikeout second strike
out of the ball game second out of the
inning two down with the runner at first
basketball sweeping a miss he blew it by
him stephen mats with his third
strikeout back-to-back case to cap off
the second maguire out number one here's
george springer 3-2 pitch to springer
ground ball up the middle that'll get
through for another hit george springer
another multi-hit game here's vladimir
guerrero jr
swinging a drive to left field the ball
is hit deep but it's going to be up
against the fence in center springer is
being stopped at third as vlady guerrero
starts a new hit streak with a double
off the center field fence base has
loaded just one out bo buchet with the
count in his favor
ground ball is short rosario will go to
second for one and that's all they'll
get iran comes in to score springer
scores but chet will get an rbi on the
fielder's choice
really good play that's short uh diving
backhanded stop by shortstop i'm ed
rosario as he dove toward third back to
back walks issued by mejia two on one
out rhys mcguire bats
ground ball fairbow past the first
baseman all the way down in the corner
gretchick's in to score and they're
stopping balera at third as louis rivera
came down the line reese maguire hit it
past the first baseman and he ends up at
second as the blue jays have extended
their lead to six to nothing looks like
they're going to make a pitching change
here and demarlo hale has called to the
bullpen justin garcia will take over
maguire's at second valeris at third
springer two for two already with a
couple of runs scored
and goes after the first pitch and
drills it to center field the straw is
going to have it go over his head two
more runs come in to score and george
springer is off to a terrific night
three at bats three hits and already he
is just a triple shy of the cycle the
indians third hit on the night and here
comes bobby bradley who bounced to third
his first time up
there's called strike three
very deliberate call by the home plate
umpire as bobby bradley is called out on
strikes and the indians with a couple of
base hits now in the fourth trying to
get on the scoreboard
the ground ball simian gloves and
quickly to his speed in time what a play
on both ends marcus simeon left his feet
pops up and then vladi guerrero with a
good stretch
they make a good defensive play in
support of steven metz blue jays leading
eight nothing as steven matz returns to
work swinging to miss another high
fastball and hedges strikes out for a
second time that's six k's for stephen
metz now the indians have runners on the
corners with two down so jose ramirez
who is over two with a couple of fly
balls to center field
there's a high pop up out into shallow
left boba's [ __ ] out calls for it and
makes the catch the blue jays have an
eight nothing lead grace mcguire draws
the wall and that will bring george
springer to the plate with another man
on
another
line drive base hit and maguire will go
to third base and george springer a four
for four game man he is swinging it so
here's vlad guerrero jr here's the one
two swung on ground ball to short
rosario to second for one miller to
first
double play
side retired punches works
this has been a welcome sight for the
blue jays to have stephen mats pitching
as well as he has tonight gabe is cut
out and missed as bradley strikes up
seven strikeouts for mats that's the
first out of the top of the sixth
calls strike three as mercado is called
out on strikes at fastball catches the
inside corner eight strikeouts for mats
ground ball off the end of the bat
swimming will gather and fire just in
time miller got down the line but the
inning is over stephen metz with a
terrific outing tonight against
cleveland three straight hits for the
indians and they load them up with
nobody out for owen miller miller two
ground downs to second and a strikeout
there's a slow breaking ball yanked down
a left field line fair
that's going to get reyes home here
comes bobby bradley mercado racing
around third he's going to score as well
it's a three-run double for owen miller
then the indians get on the board here
in the eighth inning four straight hits
to open the frame
and it is swung on smashed in the hole
and into left to base it miller stops at
third the indians down eight nothing
have five straight hits to start the
eighth and trail it eight to three and
adam simmer who's acquired from miami
and is having a good year comes on with
indians at first and third nobody out
get in the air deep enough to get the
run home hernandez will
settle under it
and that's an eight to four ball game as
owen miller comes home to score mana for
the seas making his 39th appearance as
he faces jose ramirez
swung on this is hit pretty well to
right back goes hernandez track wall go
on to the bullpen number 24 for jose
ramirez and that'll take care of jordan
romano having an easy ninth inning
suddenly it's a three-run game and the
batter will be fran mill reyes
swinging a miss he went back to the
fastball and gets the strikeout one down
bobby bradley the hitter choo-choo pitch
cut out and miss
bradley strikes out for a third time in
this game and the indians are down to
their final
so oscar mercado is the indians last
hope with the drive down eight to five
swing and a line shot to deep left field
down the line it goes
a four hit game for oscar mercado and
his second home run of the year and the
indians with two solo homers here in the
ninth inning now trail it eight to six
and now austin hedges could tie it with
one swing of the map two for four
tonight with a couple of singles
three-two pitch basketball strike him
out hermano made it interesting in the
ninth but he closes it out with a
strikeout he would eventually strike out
three batters in the ninth inning but he
gave up a pair of solo home runs but the
blue jays win it